good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday it's
hump day no it doesn't feel like it but
if you're not quarantined alone
make sure to hum something and if you
are quarantined alone like maybe try a
pillow yeah I don't know humping isn't
really like social distancing friendly
go maybe just you know maybe sit this
hump day out if there's a column in your
apartment maybe Mary Katherine Gallagher
it and the column we vacuumed ever if
you get a tree in your yard yeah baby
yard the yard uh invite me over so we
have a great show for you guys today it
is Wednesday which means our dear
toaster segment is upon us and our merch
drop is today our twinning sweatshirts
we didn't plan this but this is my
favorite item from the drop oh is it
this is actually my first time wearing
this sweatshirt on the show I just I
love an oversized sweatshirt it's
oversized sweatshirts season the season
has been extended due to quarantine so
you must get your newest oversized
sweatshirt and this one is it so the
spring merch goes on sale today at 1
o'clock p.m. Eastern Time we will
probably still be doing the show so like
we'll all do the countdown together then
you can head over there and like come in
come out we'll still be here probably
giving you bad advice under your
toasters so the spring workshop is gonna
work like this there's four items for
sale we have this sweatshirt we have the
tie-dye long-sleeve we have the white
short-sleeved t-shirt that says the
morning toast and lavender and then we
have the cropped sweatshirt that says
the morning toast those are the only
four items for sale today old merch will
not be available because the site is
specifically made for the spring merch
drop you can pre-order what you want
however many as you want whatever size
you want and you have between now and
Sunday to place your orders then orders
will be made manufactured and shipped so
you will get them in about two weeks
time yeah so it's different than all of
our other merch stops mostly because a
lot of our factories and printing
presses are not running due to karna
virus but we were able to get these four
items made so hopefully everyone can get
something that they like yeah I'm really
excited this merger is so sickening it's
so perfect for staying at home or like
you know yeah well so member when I was
talking about my like before the
quarantine was like a real thing I was
saying how I had a game night and you
were telling me to cancel it well I
didn't and I had such a good time and
then oh my I was ready toast merch and
someone was like you have any other
sweaters and like everyone came was my
bedroom and cleaned me out like litter
my dirty jeans March all my big sweaters
all my cross to bear like soap setting
so I literally have no toys merch in my
house which is why this sweater I've
been wearing non-stop because I just got
it like two weeks ago and it actually is
one of my favorites we've never made
this blue color before it's really
brings out you know the hazel in my eyes
you know what I've noticed like not to
be a trend forecast or anything but the
few things that I bought like with
spring in mind clothing wise like this
is the color of the season it's a tea
house sells it's no it's this blue like
that's the color that I will be rocking
the seats you say this is cobalt no okay
it's a sky-blue either would i I don't
know what cobalt I say it's a sky-blue
okay that's that's what I'm gonna
forecast for the season that sky-blue is
gonna be the color of a season we will
keep you updated as to when to the store
opens again that's shot morning toast
calm Oh sizing wise this is what I wear
four sizes this is just me I'm five-foot
you guys pretty much know how much I
weigh from last week's episode so do
with that what you will this sweatshirt
I'm wearing a size medium because I do
not intend to wear it with boots as a
dress because it's spring and that makes
me sweat huh so medium sized sweatshirt
in order to wear it with leggings in the
cropped t-shirt and the crop sweatshirt
I wear a size small cuz I like it super
cropped and then in the long sleeve
tie-dye I wear a size medium because
again I'm not wearing it as a dress but
I do still like it a little oversized I
wear an excel in everything except if
I'm wanting a more fitted for the long
sleeve or this sweater I'll do a large
but I just prefer everything to be
oversized because I'm fat and I don't
need anyone to know what's really going
on beneath the sweater
it's a mystery you know I walk around
with it's like Eris confusion yeah it's
like that's kind of my brand mystery you
know
whoo I love it with a perfume mystery by
me you couldn't do mystery though
because you can support from to give
away the answer objects yeah so hard you
guys and then we also were gonna recap
better pump rules and our toast movie of
the day we actually have an update which
is that and they couldn't believe it
took me almost a month to not do the
homework I do the homework I know I'm
the worst like that I know I can't
believe every night it was like a
struggle for me to put on the movie and
sometimes I don't even watch it the next
day which was a terrible idea Dinner for
Schmucks
but today last night was the first day
Claudia called me and let me know that
she would not have time in her busy
schedule it was eight o'clock and I was
gonna have dinner and watch it and then
as I was preparing to her I was like you
know what I want to have a white claw
and I just didn't want to like have a
bunch of white claws and then watch
confessions of a Teenage Drama Queen I
wanted to play Monopoly which is what I
did and then I went to bed like happy
and drunk so I let Jackie know I'm like
[ __ ] I'm not gonna watch it and she
didn't hadn't watch it either so I
didn't feel bad and we said you know
we're this one time we're gonna give
ourselves a break you know I can't
believe like for someone who literally
in college never did the reading really
never submitted homework and just all of
my schooling and I know that movies not
a homework but in in my life right now
it is the homework and I just can't
believe like I did it I feel proud like
this is the first time in a month yeah
that I forgot to do the homework we
didn't forget we made the decision that
so first of all when we started toast
movie the day was when we like thought
quarantine was like this cute little
thing we'd be here for a week everyone's
gonna be bored let's it let us do
something to help you get through but
now we are on week four of the teen
we're watching movies every day everyone
hates the movies that we pick everyone's
like suggesting left and right and like
pretty much the movies were watching
pretty make sure these only exist for
people to tell us that we should have
chosen something else totally so what we
decided was is we're gonna take two days
to watch this movie if you watch a movie
great we'll be recapping it tomorrow if
you hadn't had a chance to watch it yet
you can watch it tonight we'll be
recapping it tomorrow like I know a lot
of people listen to the show and
sometimes I forget that like the
magnitude in which like the reach we
have but I just have a feeling like 10
people participate and chose me the
other day but I could be wrong you know
you know but then it's like those 10
people showed up for a recap today
they're and I hate to disappoint people
that we were gonna start to like stretch
out the movies because sometimes there
is other stuff to watch like Vanderpump
rules so we will be recapping
Confessions of a Teenage Drama Queen
tomorrow and idea everyone can find a
way to live with that and I'm just like
so in on One Tree Hill like to get out
of it to be honest it's just not the
mental place like I watch a few episodes
last night and people were telling me
that the second season is like nothing
of the sort but the whole Jake Jagielski
and Jenny thing like I like Larry I went
to bed with tears in my eyes when like
he had to go to jail he gave the baby to
the coach like it was so beautiful and
Ben is obsessed with one tree hill like
he won't let me watch it during the day
because he's working and like I'm not
and I have to wait till he gets into bed
so it's like when he gets into bed I
don't wanna watch Confessions of a
Teenage Drama Queen even though I chose
it no I I completely understand
I feel like people will understand we'll
be recapping it tomorrow and that's that
on that you know you know what's so
Quincy I was into a really good book Oh
yesterday and so it was just like two
way different dynamics I just couldn't
toggle back and forth One Tree Hill I
totally understand yeah what's so crazy
though it's that it's like the beginning
April and I feel like normally most
people would have a pit like that it's
tax season but everything's been delayed
like we're all free yeah it's true
I think nobody sucks but we have pits
out other things but thanks to turbo tax
thanks to turbo tax you never need to
have a pit because people do amazing
things every day so it makes no sense
that they shouldn't feel confident about
doing their taxes Turbo Tax believes
that with the right tools and
encouragement people can do anything yes
even taxes and with turbo tax live you
even have access to CPAs and EAS on
demand who are available to answer your
questions or go to advice on how to file
even on nights and weekends so you can
do your taxes with ease and confidence
and never feel stuck or alone during the
tax process you can also rest assured
that you're getting the best possible
outcome which means you can file your
taxes quickly and easily and get back to
those amazing things people do every day
turbo tax all people are tax people
thanks Turbo Tax really give me the
confidence all people are tax people um
so I've been spending so much time in my
love sack and I know everyone keeps
saying like we're sponsored by love sack
we're not but if left suckers like hook
the toasters up with the code because
like they're kind of rising oh yeah we
had said oh we did a patreon episode
yesterday yeah we did a quarantine Q&A
and it was like you would think that
this whole show is quarantine Q&A but
then we got the questions and it's like
there's so much about our quarantine
that we haven't shared and our whole
conversation about our husbands and the
chores was so funny I was literally
laughing last night and I was really on
this like I got on the podcast yesterday
with a patron I was being really preachy
like you know I'm just so like happy
like me and my husband and literally
this morning like we got to the biggest
fight because you want to know why
tonight is the first night of seder and
we all placed orders Ben's dad made food
for all of us like we our fridge is full
with food Ben this morning is wrapping
and chopping in the kitchen making a
roast and I'm like what are you doing
but hey you know I know I sound crazy
for getting mad at him for cooking no
that's the craziest thing I've ever
heard well like we our fridge stinks
like fish like there's just so much
stuff in there I'm like first of all why
do meeting dishes and I just know I'm
gonna have to clean it and he's so messy
and he's like I'm making a roast I'm
like but we literally have food for 10
people for just the two of us like what
are you doing and it just started this
huge fight where he thought I was being
crazy for telling him not to cook but
I'm like you don't understand when you
cook I know you say you're gonna clean
and even if you do you don't clean the
way that is appropriate and and is
legitimate in my house according to my
standards and we just and like I was
literally laughing it's like on the
podcast yesterday I was like you know me
and Ben have gotten into this like
amazing routine and like that is true
and I was like just
acting like everything was all great and
it was until this morning like I slept
so bad last night I woke up on the wrong
side of the bed and I just fully cracked
yeah I wake up on the wrong side of the
bed every day these days and then like
it's not until at the toasts like puts
me in a good mood and then I'm able to
go home and get in a bad mood again the
toast puts me in a bad mood I mean sorry
I mean the toast puts me in a good mood
but I find that when we were doing the
show at 10:30 that's like a real morning
I was like so cranky and then once we
started I feel better the exact same
which is so scary that like now noon to
me feels like 10:30
Oh noon to me I'm definitely when I
arrived here I mean I'm in brighter
spirits and actually had a thought this
morning that I would love to run by you
know maybe this is more of a private
conversation but I would love to hear
the toasters weigh-in because I was
sinking how after all of it's like I'm
gonna say yes to life more we were both
saying right but that requires you to I
think I know where you're headed with
this and that requires me to like go out
more especially on the weekdays and like
maybe have more drinks like at least for
the next year like I fully plan on being
socially active on the weekdays and I
feel like a lot of times like I hold
myself back because I have to the show
and I wake up at like 8:30 for the show
and I think that like if we stuck with
this 12 o'clock time slot if the
toasters would allow it like that would
allow me for the next year at least to
like really live my life like and I just
I want to put it out there but and if
that's not what the toasters want like I
will 100% go back to 10:30 but I just
think like this has really caused me and
all my fellow Millennials to like really
realize that we have to put me first
yeah we have to put fun first we have to
put time spent together first we have to
put important experiences first like
Margo always makes fun of me because
what I choose to say that we're so
different like if you and I both made
$10 like you would spend $10 on a bag
and I would spend it like on a table at
a club because I'm more much more
experiential like I will fly everyone
first-class like that's how like I'm
just nuts and that's like not you you
make wise investments but like I invest
in experiences I'd be always more
experiential in the in the sense of
trips but not just so that like I can
see the world but so that I can spend
time with the people that I love in a
different place yes exactly like
literally I don't want to meet anyone
new or see anything new I just to be
with my old people and see all the old
things Blake in Turks and Caicos yeah
and in a house where we all fit yeah
yeah and like maybe there's an ocean
nearby you know yeah so I just wanted to
put it out there I'm sure the comments
are just wild right now but I want to
put it out there and then I feel as
though we're really the morning show of
the west coast so just think about it
okay
guys can think about it I will let you
know that like I that seems crazy to me
so how do we're just we're are our own
bosses like why are we waiting up so
early but it's not even so early like
real morning shows get up at like 4:00
a.m. course but we were never a real
morning I know I'm team 10:30 your team
noon maybe we'll put it to its poll in
the middle 11:30 maybe we'll put it to a
true poll like an Instagram poll voting
caucus everything will each campaign I
was gonna say look maybe we should have
a full-on dude it'll be on like November
4th yes no but this needs to happen
before November 4th so I just want to
hear everyone out I mean our numbers are
higher later in the day but also that's
just because the quarantine so yeah I I
just I wanted to put it out there and
whatever the answer is like I will truly
do what's best for the people because
that's a kind of leader I am and that's
why you should vote for me and my 12
o'clock platform and if you know if you
were happy with the way that things work
it ain't broke don't fix it and then I
you should vote for me I just think
you're more of like a regressive and I'm
more of a progressive no I'm definitely
being like stifled about change
like an old conservative Newt Gingrich
right now totally new do I need to get a
camel toe nudie you know actually I met
Newt Gingrich once yeah when I was in
high school I was on the AIPAC committee
which is the American Israeli something
and it's just basically like a weekend
for Jewish kids to like go hang out and
meet other Jewish kids and there was a
Cuba day with Newt Gingrich and I just
like when I'd even know he was he looked
like our grandma did the patron episode
Q&A yeah do do do you ask any questions
if you got any answers no um it was it
my friend Rachel and she will also admit
he was quite um you know noticed he got
a term here just like he gave that vibe
like you know like grandpa Thanksgiving
you know oh you know what though it was
like a little shoulder yeah yes the
puzzle of his shoulder yeah he gave a
little like like lower back you know
stop stop I said it okay sure it's hot
as [ __ ] in here today are you huh
yeah I'm always hot why no I'm literally
just starting an ad sorry when I say
random things Jacki things I'm starting
an ad like yeah yeah I'm feeling
nutritious today oh god no I don't
to say quite yet okay well do you think
that it's time though oh well that's a
different question okay cuz I feel like
I feel like it's time cuz we have like a
one o'clock thing happening yeah
definitely you know we just need to get
the show on the road and Deere toasters
yeah I managed to pull five stories out
of my ass today
wow you're a magician and I think it's
time to share them with you guys please
so here in the past five stories that I
pulled out of my ass that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast well since you
said it begs the question what color is
the skin by your [ __ ]
alright yes it's definitely time and I
just want to let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by
legacy box a super simple mail and
service to have all your home movies and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive DVD or the cloud do you have home
projects that you've been putting off
what's on your list cleaning out the
garage Digita digitizing and aging tapes
and photos we literally had a box of
like VCR and like cassette tapes of home
photos like five years ago that we used
to just watch all the time on like this
adapter it was like this whole
configuration I didn't even know about
legacy box I didn't know what I was
missing they help you digitally
declutter it's the easiest way to check
off this important chore because legacy
box can take care of everything you need
a fun activity to do with the family or
something to help take your mind off
things
relive your glory days dig out that box
of dusty home movies and videos and send
them to legacy box to be digitized by
hand at their state-of-the-art facility
wouldn't it be fun to go through that
dusty box of recorded moments as a
family pack them up together send them
to legacy box so they can be digitally
preserved and if you're tired of
watching the same Netflix shows you can
watch something more meaningful like
home movies um tackle this at home
project to keep you busy plus it's now
on sale
legacy box is the best thing ever I
can't believe like it wasn't invented
longer ago it's much so genius we did it
they do photos and videos so like
literally my mom it's the DVD which is a
DVD like it shouldn't be that old
couldn't even work I don't even know it
maybe it was in blu-ray I don't even
know why I couldn't work work it but I
sent it so I can see box they picked
that fix that right up for you they put
it on the cloud legacy box is actually
the perfect project for you to get
involved in right now a use of time like
bring back those memories take a trip
down memory lane and it'll give you
something to watch since no one else's
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past the process from start to finish is
so easy
plus they keep you up to date with
regular email updates throughout the
process it is the world's largest as
digitizer of home movies and photos and
as
helped over 750,000 families digitally
preserve go to legacy box comm slash
toast and save 50% while supplies last
legacy box.com slash toasts and save 50%
while supplies last you can buy today
and take advantage of this exclusive
offer send it in when you're ready but
make sure to go to legacy box.com slash
toast if you want to save 50% while
supplies last Thank You legacy box sign
on get your memories in order sign on
box up your legacy by the way th EO is
really reaching across the aisle today
ya know he's exactly what dr. Burks was
talking about like bipartisanship and
just like seeing one another
a hundred percent okay first story are
you ready ready Tom Brady had to adapt
when Gisele Bundchen quote wasn't
satisfied with our marriage excuse me
so Tom Brady was on Howard Stern I'm
sure being remote interview when he said
that his wife is quote different from
what the public perceives she's probably
very different than how people would
probably see her what's been portrayed
as a fashion model he said that she's a
very spiritual woman she believes in
trying to heal herself so there was a
couple years ago she didn't feel like I
was doing my part for the family I feel
like honestly this is our patriotic no
idea like completely about your husband
quote she felt like I would play
football all season and she would take
care of the house and then all of a
sudden when the season would end that
I'd be like great let me get into all my
other business activities let me get
into my football training and she's
still there going well when are you
gonna do things for the house right what
are you gonna take to the kids to school
and she Zack
Brady said he had to quote check himself
and made a big transition two years ago
to get things back on track
that included skipping ot a practices
with the Patriots that pepper the latter
parts of the offseason she wasn't
satisfied with our marriage so I needed
to make a change in that he also
revealed that she wrote him a heartfelt
letter that he still has a reminder for
him that life is ever-evolving quote
what worked for us ten years ago won't
work for us forever we're growing in
different ways so interesting I feel
like I think probably he like touched on
it in the very beginning when you think
of tom brady and giselle you just sing
it like beautiful people having sex like
not having problems but i like love that
they have problems not obviously like
that they have problems but like they're
just like us you know she just wants her
husband to take the trash out when she
asks not when he's ready a hundred
percent to my [ __ ] cross to bear and
i just feel like that someday
like human beings are all the same like
we all we all poop right no it's like
the great equalizer is fighting with
your husband Jeff work all suffered from
coronavirus yeah and we all just want
her husband to take the trash out when
we asked him and not when he's ready and
not when this episode is over yeah and
and it will always be there if I'm
asking for one more thing it's like also
just to put your [ __ ] PlayStation
remote away like you're done with it put
it in the drawer hide exactly video I
don't suffer from that ailment no
annoying like okay I don't mind that he
plays video games like some girls don't
like it because he's like on the couch
for hours please stay away from me for
hours I'm happy about that but what's so
annoying is he takes out the controller
and a wire and he never puts it away
like literally I will put the controller
and the wire away at least three times
today look in the morning when I wake up
because sometimes he can't sleep he'll
go and play so I'll put it back the next
morning then he plays in between calls I
put it back in the mail of the day and
then he plays before bed so right before
bed I go turn the lights off you know
clean up a little bit and I put it back
it drives me nuts that's crazy like
that's such a big part of your life in
your marriage and like that it's just
not something that's even on my radar
you have like a similar thing about
exactly does he leave like how Harry in
shot in Sex in the City left his little
tea bags everywhere Oh interesting no
just these days it's the towels oh yeah
he just abuses towels but we have a
leaky shower so it's not totally his
fault and we're his wet so you put a
towel of that exact the type of guy like
when he gets out of the shower like
he'll just splash central or he like
properly drives himself off and then
gets out of the shower
oh he properly I'm splash central you
are I'm splash I'm that mermaid Oh like
I'm just like walking around with my wet
footprints like looking for a fresh like
the girl Cleo
from h2o mm of that show and they were
all like accidentally touch water and
turn into mermaids yeah down and up no
Cleo no Joe he's not a splasher but I'm
trying to think I'm sure we have a
myriad of issues that are just
suppressing yeah yeah like you you
suppress them in your household you
can't even bring them up right now cuz
it'll like unleash this wave of of some
oceans yeah exactly exactly but I
actually feel like video games would be
a fun hobby for him and also why don't
you ever like running order a game for
yourself like there I tried but really
I'd want to say I ordered a Nintendo 64
which like is what we used to play like
with our cousins like the doctor
like with the little square remote and
it's just like Mario's like yeah and
then like if you get really far like
Luigi comes yeah I'm like jumping we're
like gasps Luigi and so I try to order
that and they don't really manufacture
them anymore and I bought like one off
of ebay and it was just didn't work so
then I'm like all right I just wanted to
play so then I did we and you could play
Super Mario on Wii and then there's a
wee sport that was like a bunch of
activities we play tennis and I just
like I never played it and now I'm like
all right let me play but he only plays
football and basketball which is like
not what I want to play like I'll play
Sonic like I played he doesn't play real
video games he plays only sports but
like why don't you like video games that
can be a one-woman show you should get a
game that you like and then you start
leaving the remote out cuz to be honest
I just can't imagine like playing a game
that's not on my phone and I have so
many games on my phone right now like
I'm really like I'm at like my threshold
honestly with games but like remember
those games we used to play when we
learn a little where the girl like she'd
go to the mall and she would go to work
and oh she would earn money oh I'm sorry
you mean the game i bought for margo for
her birthday what was that game called
um oh [ __ ] it's gonna bother me so much
Margo if you're watching please text me
um dance girl it life what was it yeah
it was like poly girl I don't even know
what I would search to find the name of
the game I mean I could actually search
my Amazon because I bought it for her
and I thought game she like she has to
get a job and she puts in a bulletin
board and she's like you know she enjoys
the fruits of her labor or maybe she
doesn't yeah and she like has to buy her
clothes
I'm calling Margaret's mother it's
honestly still in Margo's bedroom at
home okay I'm gonna check I'm gonna
patrol the comments see dream life dream
life Thank You Margo oh she picked up
yeah issue I see let her go dream life
what's good sasha has a new video on
YouTube and no get out after you watch
this video thank you that merged it is
so cute
okay it's a very high fee Cassandra can
you make me a coffee please she was this
girl who like had a bedroom and it was
so cute and like you could design her
bedroom then she went to school she had
to do chores so she had to be like
popular she'd hang with her friends but
she let be balanced to her choice you
get a job like go to the local community
center she was so well-rounded I just I
recently bought that maybe two years ago
Marta for her birthday like I just did
we played it so much as kids she never
played it like when I thought of her as
an adult but they do still make it yeah
game
like that or what was that game that you
had in your bunk dream phone do you
member that board game that you you went
when you were at camp and you wanna live
you were in the same bug and you guys
played like all those board games and
Dan you know your friend Dana yeah yeah
dream girl phone yes I don't know we
have to ask Olivia but it's like dream
comes yeah there are so many good like
games so many good games I actually just
learned to play Monopoly deal which is
like the new hot game in the minute I
don't know if you know like they gave me
communities been talking about it and
it's fabulous I'm not gonna lie it's
like a card it's a deck of cards but
it's monopoly themed and it's like super
quick games because I love monopoly but
me a man played like three hours last
night yeah cuz two people you just go in
circles uh-huh
that's tough yeah it was it was tough
for our marriage I'm sorry cuz I lost it
cuz I was gonna say maybe I should play
Monopoly with my husband but you said it
was tough on the matter no actually I
was just being dramatic
it was so fun we've been playing like
almost every night and I don't love
monopoly Ben loves it but to be honest
it's like a minimum two hours so it just
it time it passes the time yeah and
that's my bar these days my bar so low
interesting okay maybe I'll get into it
you ready for our next story yeah
another person talking about their
marriage in quarantine Tracy Morgan is
joking about quarantine sex in his Today
Show interview that a lot of
publications are calling bizarre but I
thought was [ __ ] hilarious it was
hysterical and I thought Hoda was like
really uh carrying her like he's a tough
person interview like he's such a
character I mean Joe King is he not
joking yeah but I thought she did a
great job and to be honest that's the
kind of like in-home interviews I need
because they had a premium internet
connection and that's genuinely all I
could ask for and also there was not so
much talking over each other because she
just kind of let him talk um which was
fabulous so he said him and his wife
have been quarantined in here for three
weeks so she's pregnant three times
every week she got pregnant and we're
also role-playing a lot now were
role-playing she's playing a young
maiden whose grandfather was infected
with corona virus and I'm the scientist
who discovered the cure and she'll do
anything to save her grandfather's life
and I mean anything
I absolutely love Tracy Morgan like I
fell in love with him on 30 rock and to
be honest his um it's like a random HBO
special at the Apollo is probably the
best comedy special I've ever seen like
even I would say it's better than one of
my favorite Joan Rivers ones like it is
so funny I love him so much we don't get
like
enough of him also his show the last og
the new season premiered last night
which was why he was on doing perfect
Today Show he was just talking about
everything everything under the Sun he's
talking about the Tigers at the bronze
kazoo that tested positive for curtain
virus he said I'm going to get all my
pets tested I'm gonna get my sharks
tested I'm gonna get my eel tested I
just bought a 600-pound silverback
gorilla I'm going to take him down to
New York Presbyterian and get him tested
it's just so funny like when you read it
like it's funny obviously but he's such
like his voice is so funny I just think
everything that he does is so funny and
we don't see a lot of him because he
doesn't really need to work cuz he has a
lot of money from like working but then
also he's Walmart made his money on the
road he said he said he made his money
on the road he didn't get hit by a rain
more and Flanigan truck he got hit by a
Walmart truck right so I I mean and um
on his episode of comedians and cars who
they talked a lot about it because Jeff
Jerry was trying to like find out how
much he got and they and uh Howard Stern
talked about it in his book to their
everyone's wondering how much you got
Howard Stern in the book said he heard
it was 90 million that's so crazy and he
lives in New Jersey so he was like a low
cost of living like low taxes and I
think life is good for Tracy Morgan and
his family and obviously I wish I was
his daughter or his wife but he's also
they've all been through a lot and he
has an extra appreciation for all of our
health care workers and the people who
work in hospitals and the nurses who
take care of people and it was actually
like a very it was a hilarious interview
people want to call pisar I thought it
was really sweet and treviño it was
really a rollercoaster of emotions
because when he was talking about how he
is so much respect for like health care
workers and how he so likes officer yeah
he saw on like a regular day like when
he was in the hospital like there you
know working so hard it like was really
endearing yeah also funny it was
honestly a great interview I saw it all
over Twitter and people were like
cutting moments that they thought were
funny I thought it was great interview I
thought it was a great interview if you
haven't seen it it's just a fun he's
hilarious it's like obviously fun clip
and when I was watching the clip I was
thinking like when people ask me like
who's your favorite comedian I always
say Joan Rivers but I think I need to
start saying Joan Rivers and Tracy
Morgan yeah I'm gonna add him to my
avatar as well they they just have it on
the Delta flight which is the first
place I saw it and I remember like not
being able to breathe on the plane I
think it's on HBO now it's Tracy Morgan
at the Apollo you just watch it recently
did we yeah like together Oh on a trip
like in the movie room no I think it was
just after Shabbat one night was just
I'll watch it yeah whatever it's
phenomenal
agree on anything to watch and so he on
him yell if you want to watch it find it
it's so good so good okay anyways next
up interesting story I'm looking forward
to getting your thoughts on I will try
to remain positive
Netflix launches an Instagram live
series with nois Antonio Joey King and
Jerry from cheer the weekly series want
to talk about it will feature the
streamers ye stars discussing how to
best take care during the corona virus
pandemic okay let me just say I was
ready to be negative until you said
Jerry's name I know it's and he is
positive and I bet and I like Joey King
too so I wouldn't have rolled my eyes at
that obviously like Noah Centennial
going on Instagram why by giving us all
mental health updates it's just like
genuinely not what I mean like him I
think he's so handsome but I like him
too but I don't need him there's certain
things I need him to do like to fulfill
for me and just my Instagram live is not
one of them and of course like my mind
just goes to a negative place because we
don't need more Instagram live content I
just I can't stress that enough so I
know Netflix is like okay we have young
adult stars and Instagram like it's like
an old person's mentality like young
people young people be together like I
mean so I totally get like the corporate
mindset behind putting this together but
I just I literally could not find any
Instagram stories last night because I
was so wiping through people's lives
like you usually and Margaret like the
first people who come up I have a whole
pile of lives that I did not bebe Rexha
like it was just so anyway but you know
what I was actually tuned in to be beer
excess for ten seconds
she had 70 thousand people watching like
when I went up and I'm just so
interested in the numbers the people are
watching these things yeah I'm
interested in the numbers like we were
talking about Miley Cyrus it's like
numbers really declining so it's like
what are the you have to listen to the
data what does the data say people don't
want this but bebe Rexha has been going
live a lot I don't know why I follow her
but I just like her and she has seventy
thousand people tuning in like people
listen to the data people won't be
direct sup I don't know sometimes I
accidentally get I like seriously it's
an accident I click on someone's why
because the notification comes up when
I'm trying to do something else yeah and
I'm like in someone's live and maybe I'm
counting towards that 70,000 maybe
70,000 people just accidentally hit a
notification that's why the numbers are
so busy but it was in the middle of the
live stream I didn't get the
notification she was already like I
don't care who's going live with whom oh
I would love to turn those notes I don't
care about someone that I don't follow I
gotta know
someone blank that I don't follow is
going live with seven did you follow
that's why people keep going live
together like they think if you go live
with someone else with a lot of
followers like it'll boost everyone no
it'll just annoy more people yeah the
opposite or you know what maybe there
are people who like it therefore some
people will be happy that they got the
notification yes so I personally can
pretty much make a commitment to not
watching this Netflix Instagram live
series you know I also just don't like
about this whole live thing is people if
you want to go live like and just be fun
and have fun with your friends or like
conference and fans like Justin Bieber
has been doing it like conferencing and
fans like making people's lives that's
okay like when you start to brand it
like a TV show like that's where the
thirst comes in like Miley's being right
minded she's like graphics and in a
whole art department with like Netflix
to like it's a series like I don't like
the the economization of like live
streams do you know what I mean like the
branding and the whole thing I did the
marketing yeah it's it's not that
serious
yeah and I think some people are doing
it like with good intentions like they
just want to go live like I've been
going live a lot like just because I
like going live but the whole like
making it into a big ordeal is just
where I personally I'm gonna draw the
line but again if you like it continue
to watch it and I'm really really happy
for you so some more information on the
live stream the stars will talk with
mental health experts from organizations
such as the National Alliance on Mental
Illness Mental Health America The Trevor
Project crisis text line and American
Foundation for Suicide Prevention / the
company the actors and mental health
professionals will discuss the questions
many young people are facing during the
current a virus outbreak among them what
helps if you're having trouble sleeping
I'm having so many she will sleep in
meet you I would literally up all night
up all night can't fall asleep for hours
when I'm usually the type of person like
head pillow dead no and I'm so exhausted
I literally could not sleep all night I
that's actually interesting I didn't
realize they might have something to do
like with the quarantine because I feel
like it makes sense because you know a
lot of people aren't doing much during
the day you're laying in bed all day so
yeah you're not tired at night and
you're waking up later right I am
[ __ ] wiped out and intensely and I
actually been purposely not spending so
much time in bed I've been on my loveSac
so if you like when I'm getting to bed I
should be like ready for bed but I
cannot sleep
oh my god it's bothering me so much and
I thought it was because last week I
took a muscle relaxer like a few nights
in a row because my back was hurting so
much like dependence right so I thought
that's why I was having trouble sleeping
but it's so annoying yeah other
questions how do you stay connected
during social distancing how do we
manage anxiety what does self-care
actually mean I know this might be like
a crazy thing to say but like as someone
who like is very comfortable talking
about her mental health I find like
listening to experts like really to like
make me anxious do you know any mean
like watching a live stream with a bunch
of professionals about like sleeping and
a mental health and self-care like that
would make me anxious like I just would
rather watch TV like obviously
everyone's different and how they care
for themselves mentally but I just like
honestly that way you just described
sounds like terribly anxiety and do sing
and really boring honestly yeah I I
don't disagree yeah but you know I hope
it does help someone out there who is
struggling yeah if it can help one
person it's worthwhile
did you see there's all this drama going
on on Twitter about like billionaires
donating like certain amounts of money
cuz like Jeff Bezos donated a hundred
million dollars you know what actually
that's a perfect segue into our next
story oh great is it also a perfect
segue into my ad let's see what do you
know it is for all of our sakes we need
to avoid crowds any way we can right now
but what if you need to go to the post
office and by the way post office is
definitely an epicenter of I was just
walking social distancing six feet apart
and I noticed that outside of like the
post Center there was a line of people
like six feet apart and also so it's
poppin' oh wow well that's why you need
stamps calm what if you need postage to
send out letters and packages
don't worry stamps calm is here to help
anything you can do at the post office
you can do at stamps calm print postage
on demand and skip those lines and
crowds at the post office plus you can
actually save money with the discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office or anywhere else
you are hunkering down right now whether
you're a small business sending invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
are you're just working from home and
each mail stuff stamps.com can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready just leave it in your mail
carrier schedule a free package pick up
or drop it in the mailbox no human
contact is required it's that simple and
like we said stamps comm you get great
discounts to five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off usps
shipping rights you know at my first
internship
my whole job with stamps.com like
because we were sending out like
packages and stuff and I had never heard
of Sam's common I'm like this is legit I
thought they were gonna be making me
when I heard my job I could make me run
to the post office like every day I hate
the post office but no you they just
came and picked it right up and I was
like on my computer very Tyra Banks
Allah life-sized on it
stamps.com is a no-brainer especially
now saving you time and money keeping
you safe in these crazy times
right now our listeners can get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast
that's stamps comm enter toast at the
microphone at the top of the homepage
stay safe my friends with stamps calm
love it Simon get your stand get your
stamps got a love letter to send stamps
are calm stamp it up stamp Boop okay all
right ello ma hos stamp it up yeah I'm
ready
Jack Dorsey is setting inside 1 billion
dollars for charity so this is the
thread that I read it was like his net
worth is 3 billion dollars so like he's
really setting aside 30 percent of as
well he's setting aside a quarter of his
wealth to fund new charitable causes
with the immediate focus on current of
iris relief efforts Jack Dorsey is the
Twitter co-founder and CEO so then also
is like the major investor in square
which is that payment yeah yeah no he's
like a bet he's a tech what I would
consider a tech guru yeah he's very sick
yeah but so then this happened off the
heels of Jeff Bezos donating one hundred
million dollars um there was like some
crisis that needed 100 million dollars
and Jeff Bezos gave it and so people
were like donating shaming him which I
hate because so his net worth is 122
billion dollars so to him a hundred
million dollars is to the average person
$50 which is so crazy like the whole
like it's just so [ __ ] up but like
people weren't so crazy I know people
were like coming for him like because it
was on the same day as Jack Dorsey who's
not poor by any means but his but Jeff
Bezos is wealthy one twenty two billion
verse 3 billion like this guy setting
aside a billion dollars but so I would
just love to take the temperature on
people like where do we stand with
donation shaming like cuz to be honest
when when someone was like he only gave
100 million I'm like sure the [ __ ] that
you give 100 million but then I saw him
like $50 I'm feeling really conflicted
about it like but at the same time like
this
particular crisis and needed a hundred
million dollars and hundred million
dollars is what they gave you know and
at some point maybe I'm wrong I just
feel like with this crisis at some point
like it's not that we it's not for lack
of money it's for lack of other stuff
like we can't stop the pandemic like
money can't stop the pandemic right so
I'm feeling conflicted I would love to
hear the audience's opinion on donation
Shane here's how I feel about donation
chiming even if some if every single
person who could gave $50 that would be
fabulous right you know that's true and
if someone gave $50 I wouldn't say oh
you only gave $50 like thank you for
giving $50 as opposed to zero I know
it's easy to like go after Jeff Bezos
cuz he's just like such an easy target
with those text messages and that
girlfriend and all the money um and also
people just like want to slam Amazon for
the way that they're doing things and
codes and there's and there are all of
those arguments but I think people just
like like to villainize Jeff Bezos
and I'm not saying that you should or
should in um but charity is charity and
also that's a hundred million dollars
that you do know about there's very high
possibility that he's donating money
that you don't know about and he's not
gonna go out and be like but I you know
yeah I just feel like everyone calm calm
down with the particular Jeff Bezos
situation I I'm I just wish people would
like talk more about the fact like he's
just like the founder of Amazon I'm like
there's so much fucked-up [ __ ] happening
like an amazon fulfillment centers like
I've been seeing all this stuff like
let's focus on that as opposed to like
mad at him for 100 million like that's
stupid but there are actual gripes with
Jeff Bezos said I would like love for
people to get into yeah dig in um yeah I
don't know I'm not here for donation
change no I don't think I am either
there's so much like shame around
donation like of a person if a celebrity
like with Kylie's she donated a million
dollars and everyone's like that's like
me donating ten dollars
thank you for your ten dollars though
totally donate ten dollars and with the
Kylie thing people were also saying like
well the celebrities think are only
doing it for public whatever like if we
know about it so it's like if you didn't
know about it you would give her [ __ ]
for being a billionaire and not donating
but so now you do know about it and
you're mad that you know about it like
which one which one you're damned if you
do you're damned defeat that happens
with Taylor Swift all the time she like
she told everyone is she donated the
money like who cares if the money is
being donated I don't care if you put it
on a [ __ ] billboard right I don't
know then it's like an ominous you know
no but you know what well that's like
that episode yeah anyways he will
transfer Jack Dorsey
transfer 1 billion dollars of his equity
and square the digital payments company
he also co-founded to a limited
liability company called start small he
said in a series of tweets on Tuesday he
said that that amount accounts for 28%
of his wealth that's so crazy begging
and you think it's like why would
someone do that but sometimes it's like
you have enough money like I think yeah
at a certain point I mean you can only
buy so many things right how many houses
in so many islands and as someone who
like is so money hungry and like greed
takes over my whole life like if I had
three billion dollars I can never
imagine giving a billion dollars away
but at the same time like I actually
think a billion dollars is enough money
for me to live on like I'd be good with
a billion you know yeah I don't know
yeah so it's like if I had three like I
actually could kind of magic at some
point it's like you don't need that much
if it's 3 billion or 4 billion it's like
it's really the same yeah yeah at a
certain point at that point yeah at that
point like you've bought all the houses
you can buy like that's it sure there's
really only so much you can buy so I
think that this is wonderful yeah I
think this is wonderful as well all
charity is wonderful all charities
charity charity in the charity world and
I think that like I want to hear from I
want to hear from you on what she thinks
about charity shaming should be launched
at enn podcast hosted by Leeanne Locken
called Leeanne Locken
the charity charity world the charity
world or charity shaming oh no idea
shaming with I think let me just be a
segment of the charity world it's like
yeah
charity change she is a charity expert
so I would love to just hear her stance
on this particular charity shaming event
yeah and I feel like she would
participate in charity shaming of course
you know yeah of course if she said well
the Wescott's gave me a totally like
comparing her ledger okay and final
story face book launch is a new chat app
for couples we're gonna have to stop
launching stuff and you know what now
that was donation shaming where's my
Zuckerberg bin where's his donation ins
is Devin eight or he's doing it quietly
not in this link that's what he wants
you to think you know Sigmar target was
probably donating he's just so humble he
did it silently Facebook Inc on Tuesday
launched a new messaging app for couples
called tuned that allows them to chat
share photos and music as well as have a
timeline of shared memories the app is
currently available only on Apple's App
Store in the US and Canada
according to data from industry sight
sensor tower so what's the point is it
for couples like who are married yeah or
maybe like in a long-term relationship
they have basically like their own
timeline which I guess you could just
click see friendship but then you can
like share photos up with just each
other
is it a chat app or it's um a mess I
don't know it allow it's a messaging app
that allows them to chat share photos
and music as well as have a timeline of
shared memories okay I just like sort of
get how it's different from iMessage and
whatsapp no but it seems like a dramatic
to have another app oh it's just to talk
about a person it's beyond dramatic
unless you're like a polygamist but for
the most part but it's also like it's a
place where you could just like have a
wall you know sometimes like in your
text messages like you would have to
scroll two three years ago to see what
you guys were up to but like this is a
place where you put like post milestones
in your relationship to be honest I like
never really forgave Facebook for making
me download a separate app for messenger
and like they really genuinely like as a
consumer they lost me after that yeah
they lost me after that for sure and the
new Facebook homepage did you get it yet
yeah I'm on your computer I don't [ __ ]
with it oh my god the notifications are
so annoying like it takes up 30% of the
page it's awful I literally clicked it
like you want the new Facebook I'm like
sure biggest mistake of my life
no I don't want the new anything from
Facebook just like give me my morning
toasters groups and get that [ __ ] out of
my face how do you remember when we were
like in high school and Facebook changed
it's like main homepage like a million
times and all these hacks to like get
the old Facebook that I know and like it
turns out at the end of the day like
they were right yeah you know but it's
also because we don't have a choice so
right we acclimated it's adapt or die
adapt or die so you want to do to your
toasters next or benefit all's they do
from girls they think okay it was a
boring episode like they're back to
putting on bad content which it's good
for them um
Jana's birthday I just absolutely love
Dana that whole argument was Sheena was
so stupid like Sheena is just so
two-faced like Dana literally went out
of her way to do the right thing and
somehow still ended up like in a fight
with Sheena yes she did more than she
needed to do even like going to talk to
her in the first place was like so over
the top but like she just wanted to
doubt her eyes and cross her T's and
then it turns out that that wasn't
enough for Sheena yeah Sheena I don't
even think the word is two-faced like I
don't and the thing is when she was
crying a lot there's a part
that's self-aware it's like I can't
identify what the issue with Sheena is
other than like she's not two-faced in
the sense that she'll like talk say
something to you and then say something
else behind her back but like she like
she hides her feelings like she lied
about looking back she lied about right
but why is she like what is she hiding
yeah it's weird to said she's
embarrassed to admit that she likes max
or that she likes bread I think she's
like a huge fear of rejection and so she
lied and said that she was cool with
them going out together and she lied
about saying that she would ever even
care cuz she never even liked mac so she
never even liked Bret when she actually
liked both of them she's just so afraid
to admit her feelings when she's 34 like
you don't think that when you're
shooting for you would have that pice
acting like a seventh grader yeah but as
a 34 year old and it just doesn't it
doesn't add up
especially when there may be
conversations in relationships with
mature people like Dana who just can't
be talking to a seventh grader fighting
over a boy with a seventh a she's
talking to Lala and she's talking to
Dana both of who are like actually
emotionally like mature and it's even
that it's making the difference between
their levels of maturity like that much
more obvious yeah it's really painful to
watch and I just I don't get it it's
like we're all you know well-rounded
adults here like we just we have
emotions and we share them with the
class like it's just not that crazy but
when Dana was talking about how her
birthday it's kind of hard because of
her mom and she like moved from Seattle
a year ago and like she didn't expect
have so many friends at her birthday
party like to have so much fun like I
just love her so much like she's
learning my favorite character no I love
her so much when Lisa like had so much
respect for her to like come to the
birthday party wow that was crazy I know
and like meet her sister and I just I
thought it was all so beautiful like she
is such a like a mainstay like she's
just everything on the sword and the the
poolside lunch between Ariana Lala and
Dana so it was just like so fabulous and
I sure remember that day they posted an
Instagram yes and they were like
introducing the new cast member and was
probably like not even confirmed if she
was gonna be full-time but they were
like this girl's everything like we're
going all in on her yeah honestly like
the new P putting up with people like
Danica and Charlie like are only worth
it because we got Dana I mean Charlie at
least there's something interesting
about her and Rudy ID like she's not the
worst no I got to Hanaka like a mother
in the preview for next week she's
having the same conversation that she
had with Dana about Max now with Brad
like I just don't think Brett's are a
guy for you like shut the [ __ ] up and
honestly why isn't Anika been fired
she's an awful employee yeah when they
like did all the flashbacks of all the
stuff she's done I'm like what kind of
mess is Lisa Vanderpump running this
girl
jerks be fired she deserve to be fired
after getting physical with her
boyfriend or at least in mode it's like
why is she managing these people yeah
like she's in charge of Raquel but
honestly Raquel is more responsible
really cute no I know what she's like
hit the bull's eye with the axe and like
I actually she's really starting to grow
on me no she's really really starting to
are me and Lala posted after last week's
episode like you know I think things are
good between them and that makes me
really happy yeah it seemed like Lala
got some backlash for it yeah and I
think she probably felt bad but she also
was like I'm creating great TV I'm gonna
do what I have to do um can I just point
out that the person who put Dana's face
in the cake which thankfully she was
okay with was Tom's animal of course it
was of course it was extra and like
literally I wouldn't know about it and
she's so cool Dana like she it's not the
type of person who would have gotten mad
at that but like that's grounds for
getting mad like it's it's my birthday
like I have a face on we're filming like
what the [ __ ] you doing yeah
the episode actually started off the
heels of like that terribly awkward
argument between Katie and Tom and to be
honest like the reconciliation was not
at all what I would have allowed in my
house I know and it's like I thought
that maybe he was like in a drunk State
or like just on something that just made
him turn into like the devil yeah but
the fact that he's like explaining how
he got to that place I'm not just like
on like oh my god I don't know what came
over me
no he was just like no you did this and
it made me feel this way therefore I was
disgusted I'm like a boy yeah and he's
like I was turned off not sexually but
like emotionally he just like woke up
and obviously like regretted his tone
but not the message you know not like
what led him there whereas the whole
thing was just so off he was honestly
the strangest argument between a couple
that I've ever seen and honestly beau
got a more sincere apology from Tom
Schwartz than Katie got from him it was
really weird and now the next week
they're gonna go like make their
marriage legit yeah that's so weird but
honestly that's it that looks like so
much fun
honestly like it if I had found if I
found out like me and been more at
legally married like I'd be kind of
happy like we even go it to Vegas and do
another celebration like that sounds so
fun yeah I mean you would love more than
anything to do your wedding over yeah oh
my god well that's what that's what I
get for getting married first like I
made all the mistakes at my wedding so
you know let me can have perfect
weddings and you know like you're
welcome yeah you guys actually never
properly thanked me but you're welcome
yeah it's true I mean yeah it's true the
other thing that happened was the whole
Stassi beau fiance drop I mean
it's just like so real but I just
honestly hate watching it because I know
that they're gonna get I know that
they're engaged now in their life so
it's like I don't need to see what got
them there yeah and also it looks like
this week like they have this fight next
week he asked for her father's
permission they go to Vegas and so the
week after do they actually gotta get a
check three weeks lead-up for an
engagement like it's a lot that's a lot
come on give it give it to us we deserve
it we've sat through a lot of [ __ ] yeah
where it's like with Jackson Britney
like they just went to lunch and he
proposed like there was no lead-up we
had like a three week we'd lead up to
Jackson Brittany's wedding and I
understand but like a three week lead up
to a proposal that's just that's pulling
teeth y'all stassi's supposed to be
getting married in Italy right yeah in
the fall and they haven't postponed yet
and I don't know that they'll need to I
don't know if they will either yeah but
they also shouldn't like do it yet
because there's enough time figure it
out um the final thing was the whole
wish its of WeHo drama they went to that
horrible lunch like why would they be
having lunch like the conversation
really could've been the text message I
don't know and like they were at a table
for six when they were only three people
yeah but I think there was like a
filming thing so they could all be
seated I see all the time in restaurant
yeah it was really weird and I have to
say like even though I think generally
speaking I'm I'm I agree with like
Stassi I don't agree with Katie um and I
feel for Kristen
I feel like Katie's taking a much harder
line against Kristen and Stassi like if
Stassi were renewing her vows in Vegas
or having a wine night Kristen would be
invited but yeah she definitely like
wants to keep Kristen at bay but not
like completely destroy her life and
remove her from a television show and
the gun crew and have Charlie Raquel and
Danica at her house and not her sister
yeah like it's the the reaction of Katie
but because pretty much like this whole
fight started because of Carters like
you're gonna remove someone literally
from your life because you don't agree
with their choices I feel like stassi's
handling it how I would handle it like
if someone's annoying me like with their
choices like I'm not gonna be mean to
them and I'm not gonna cut them out of
my life but I'm just gonna like take
away exactly social distance that's
that's a normal reaction I don't know
why Katie's like coming first so hard I
feel like there's something else going
on because the reaction is not adding up
with what happened yeah and like this I
understand that right now if things
aren't good but like your guys are at a
birthday party Kristen pulls you aside
and immediately starts crying and this
is someone who at one point was your
best friend when you guys weren't even
friends with Stassi like a sister how do
you not
like a small space in your heart when
the crime is really that she's just like
in a bad relationship and being a [ __ ]
she didn't she didn't hurt someone that
you love like I don't I don't understand
why they're taking such a hard line
against her I think it's cruel I think
it's cruel to like when she found out
about big it's like that was really sad
like her gonna charge like in her little
car on her phone and I was like put your
[ __ ] phone down DRI yes be her get
home and take the call you know and like
she just has to keep calling scheana for
like information it's really sad and she
was like I wasn't invited either I'm
like but we never expected you to be
invited Jeana yeah I know it would have
been worse if she and was invited yeah
I'm Danica and Charlie yeah like for
sure but actually next week in Vegas
looks really fun yeah I bet I don't
remember that happening on social media
I do and I also remember it they were
like thirsting it out at Vanderpump
garden cocktails and everyone's like
this is where they're gonna start a show
with the Vanderpump cocktail garden
people like this will be the crossover
like how would she know walked in from
Beverly Hills yeah you know names but
it's but I don't know that's happened
true we'll see if we get to know any of
the staff at Vanderpump cocktail Arden
yeah I don't I hope I don't need another
no we're getting to the new Jen at
Vanderpump rules at Sur and I'm liking
them they're they're cool I like I love
Dana love I'm cool with Charlie I think
she's funny she's not like anyone else
I've ever encountered on television
Danica's so lame I could die whoa
divides and marquel is growing on me and
Ariana and scheana are like joint next
gen which is interesting for Ariana that
she would do that cuz she hates the show
so yeah
going with the graduates would be a
great place for her to like kind of
graduation out you know and not like she
doesn't have to be like Sheena totally
you know pretend to like like scheana
wants me on the show forever so if she's
with the young people she has five more
years right but why wasn't Sheena at the
axe-throwing then because it was oh yeah
it was I don't know like the whole the
group makes no sense to me
yeah no just that Ariana piece like
graduate you don't even like it here
yeah but I would say just Inc Ariana
wants to be like friends with cool
people and I think that in her mind like
this new group of people like haven't
been corrupted yet by Fame perhaps so
that's it should we move on to deer
toasters which is our advice segment if
you ever want advice email us dear
toasters at gmail.com
we always keep it anonymous even if you
write your name like some girl literally
wrote her full name today and I cut it
out anything from wedding stuff
Quarantine stuff anything the weirder
the better so it's dere toasters at
gmail.com and our segment for dere
toasters is brought to you by materia
driven by the belief that high
performance skincare should should and
can be non-toxic skin compatible and
affordable Natori I'm was born their
mission is to create safe clinically
effective biocompatible products that
deliver visible results with prices
ranging from 16 to 25 dollars yet at the
sales that match or exceed similar
products that are double triple or in
some cases 18 times the price nutriyum
formulas utilize cutting-edge technology
to harness the healing powers of
ingredients found in nature their
products are proudly made in the USA
their cruelty fee paraben free gluten
free non-toxic fragrance free and
dermatologist tested while it may seem
safe to assume that all skin care
products would be compatible with skin
the assumptions would be wrong in fact
there are hundreds of thousands of
skincare products in the marketplace
that have safe peat had that have unsafe
pH levels utilized materials that cause
irritation and inflammation to the skin
or are known to be toxic nutrient
believes it's impossible to it's
impossible to achieve healthy nourished
skin with formulas that are unbalanced
or incompatible and only use ingredients
that either directly benefit the skin's
health or support the integrity and
effectiveness of their formulations with
hundreds of ingredients banned on their
know list and an in-depth online
ingredient library that lists the
purposes and use of every single
ingredient using their formula nutriyums
number one priority is safety and
transparency and jackie and i both had
the esteemed honor and pleasure of
getting like almost all their products
and they're fabulous they are fabulous
my quarantine routine has been totally
changed by natori i'm so what i've been
doing now is every night i'm switching
off between using i use a vitamin c
serum and face oil one night and then
the next night i use retinol face oil
serum and cream and like honestly I'm
obsessed I'm obsessed with the retinol I
was a little expensive but it's so
expensive but I love it like then your
face starts just like peel off your
ending shiny new baby skin yeah um and
it's really like I feel like a lot of
people are focusing on self care during
quarantine and like this is the perfect
time to switch up your like face routine
you can do things that you might not
normally do or have the time to do and
I'm so grateful for a materia it's like
it's everything the sort and they're
products you can get a retinol from
between sixteen and twenty five dollars
I have a retinol that's about 98 dollars
can you believe that and I don't like it
know what a waste
can't believe it
they're offering a special promo code
for all toasters to receive a free multi
peptide ice I cream with any purchase of
two items or more only Aetna turian comm
and 80 you are um comm add an eye cream
to any purchase of two items or more and
use code toast to receive your eye cream
for no cost
that's an attorney I'm na T u RI um
dot-com and they use the code toast
Thank You nitiram love it
definitely has been one of the better
things for me during quarantine just
want to remind you before we do dr
toasters the spring merch collection
drops in six minutes and 30 seconds
so that's enough time to do two coasters
yeah yes of course during these
quarantine times I have nothing better
to do than turn tuning into the apps to
meet for me to meet someone let's face
it I've been on the apps while before
the pandemic I'm single by definition
and when honestly love to be in a
relationship I met this guy on hinge and
we really hit it off he's a nice Jewish
boy we are constantly chatting we text
til the wee hours of the morning and he
still likes talking to me he said it not
me it's making me nervous because we are
really opening up to each other personal
stories family divorces and now snapchat
if you know what I mean if this wasn't a
pandemic I'm sure he would have grabbed
a drink by now and we talked about the
different dates we want to do when
things return to the new normal
he has said a few times that our minor
he has said a few things that are minor
red flags but I actually can laugh out
loud in his text is this love or is this
the corona goggles thank you for the
content we need honestly I was all for
this love story until you mentioned the
snapchat thing I feel like you guys like
sending pictures of your dick and your
titties like makes it not romance like I
know that's like such a provincial eye
of thinking but I just feel like that
makes it more like a penpal like catfish
moment not like we're gonna go on a date
after this moment no I actually I don't
agree I don't think the snapchat thing
doesn't change anything for me other
than like wow um but when you said that
you guys are like sharing deep things
about yourself like when you have all
these conversations virtually via text
message I don't know if you're
facetiming hopefully you are or talking
on the phone cuz that does make it more
personal but then sometimes when you
meet the person and it's just like not
there automatically um now it's like
this person knows all this stuff about
you it's just it's kind of weird I on
the one hand I feel like this is a great
time to meet people and beyond dating
apps and start chatting people up and
and maybe weeding out people who you
would actually want to get really get to
know on a date but I wouldn't share too
much otherwise when you guys meet each
other it's gonna be a letdown because
like what else is there right you might
not have anything to say you know but
Olivia
and Zack met on hinge or J swipe and
they chatted so much before they ever
actually met because he was living in
Philly em was in the process of moving
back to New York and look what happened
to them so I just think it's every way
it's not always a bad thing but like
there should be a little mystery yeah
sometimes and I don't know I think it
could be I think it could be true love I
don't think it's Corona goggles cuz I
don't think you can like talk all day
and all night to someone that year that
doesn't make you laugh honestly this is
love as mind yeah except that you've
seen the person so you digitally yeah I
don't know I I see an interesting social
experiment I'd love an update yeah keep
going down this road yeah just you know
don't give it all like you need there
needs to be something exciting about the
time that you guys like first each other
other than like that exactly yeah you
know please keep us updated I would love
to know like how this ends like this
um this could be like a quarantine
romance I love it love it okay thanks
for reading I'm optimistic I do um deer
toasters I'm writing in because my
husband is truly being nothing of the
sort
I'm a financial analyst and I've been
working from home he is a paralegal and
is considered essential so he's been
going into his office every day for some
reason he thinks that because I have
been staying home every day I've just
been chilling but reality
I work seven to seven five days a week
with no lunch break but since the stock
market has been so insane
he doesn't have to be at work till 9:00
and literally just sleeps until 8:30
well I'm up at 6:30 working for a hour
and a half while he's snoozing away he
consistently makes comments and asked me
to do various things around the house
while he is at work and I'm like I'm at
work too I just can't get up and fold
laundry or empty the dishwasher in the
middle of the workday and he just thinks
work from home is so relaxed and chill
but it's been more intense than normal
with the financial climate right now he
constantly makes comments like must be
nice to go to to be wrapped up in a
blanket working in sweats while I go
into work like yeah but I'm still
working and that perk of work from home
gets old really quick I've been working
60 hour weeks and he works 37 how do I
help him understand that working from
home doesn't mean I'm chilling watching
Netflix but that I'm actually working
well your husband sounds like a dick
honestly I feel like this is something
before the quarantine um that what
happened in my house - it was like I do
work for mom and it's different cuz I
don't work 37 hour weeks and I'm not a
financial analyst yeah but it's like
there's this assumption that like this
stuff is gonna fall on me because like
I'm home and like I'm a woman but it's
honestly would let's know if the roles
were reversed and like Ben was working
for a woman he a lot of time if I would
just like expect him to do the laundry
yeah I asked him to and I'd probably
come home and he would just be starting
that's really hard I don't know how you
can show him like prove to him that you
know you don't have that sort of time
while you're working it from home um I'm
sorry I called your husband a dick that
was like a little bit of no because I
understand why he's has these
assumptions cuz I feel the same way to
him it's like oh you're working from
home like you could you know literally
Ben is so busy and like just literally
do one day she's like it's not like you
just left your dish into things like
could you leave that for and you could
put it in I understand you're busy I am
yeah but you could put it in the dish I
just feel like you had no problem
confronting us about it like you seemed
like you know exactly what's going on
like just be upfront like honestly if
quarantine has taught me anything about
relationships is that community
communication is everything so like
literally just be upfront be like hey
[ __ ] I know you're working 37 hours a
week but I'm working seven date and you
need to [ __ ] off yeah I stand up for
yourself maybe he feels like he can tell
you what to do because you're not
responding in any way that would suggest
otherwise or you come from a place of
like you are hurting my feelings I'm
working so hard you do not see that I
don't care if like you don't even
recognize how I work but just like stop
giving me more work like I need ya to
appreciate how hard I'm working from
right but like just don't add more to my
plate and don't belittle my I hate like
that's also like the biggest problem
here's like don't belittle my career
just because given the current climate I
happen to be working for a right it
really sounds like homegirl is quite
successful as a financial adviser I'm
sorry don't belittle that I know what
you have to do I'm sorry I forgot how
[ __ ] petty I am yeah he's sleeping
when you start working an hour and a
half work from the bedroom typing away
typing away on calls he'll see how hard
you're working and I'll shut the [ __ ] up
yeah I'm sorry I just totally forgot
that whole part like where to me the
most egregious part of all this is like
him not taking your career seriously
when to be honest it sounds like you're
more successful than him yeah I would
say like get up at 6:30 um
maybe even just do something close on
your hair just to make noise and just to
prove that your [ __ ] just to show him
how busy you are and then like say for
some reason like the Internet and living
rooms like not good you have to work
from the bedroom to typing away and then
maybe like you know just buck around and
start typing someone yeah I get like a
landline have it ring at 6:30 yeah I
guess that would do that if like the
first approach doesn't work with us on
and then if that doesn't work just be
like oh you know what I'm I'm right I
can work for my bed type type type while
you're [ __ ] sleeping I would love to
know what you're more upset about is it
the expecting you to like do chores or
is it like the belittling of your
livelihood because honestly that's what
makes me more mad I think it's both they
both hurt they both hurt okay and I
don't what together compounded even
worse final Deere toasters tear toasters
I'm a typical millennial New York gal
who sought refuge from the pandemic by
escaping the city and gone my
boyfriend's parents house in Connecticut
big mistake we've been here for three
weeks now and things have been going
pretty smoothly until last night it
started by me my boyfriend and his
parents having some wine and watching TV
after dinner after a little while my
boyfriend and I decided to watch our own
movie down in the basement about 15
minutes or so go by we're watching this
movie and my boyfriend suddenly gets up
and disappears for like 10 minutes merch
is live y'all merch is live okay let's
finish episode um we live together so I
know his ways and I honestly thought he
was just pooping keep in mind his
parents are right upstairs said of Lee I
hear a few voices and footsteps coming
down the stairs to the basement I'm
sitting on the couch watching this movie
minding my own business then this odor
hits me he's been busted by his parents
smoking weed in the basement I get a
major pin why do I feel like I'm back in
high school about to get in trouble
we're about successful 26 jolted outs
but I don't want his parents thinking I
don't respect them or do drugs do I take
the fall with my man help sincerely a
ride-or-die [ __ ] absolutely not
and your man should not expect you to
take the fall they're his parents and
let's say you were smoking weed just you
your boyfriend should still take the
fall because your relationship with his
parents is more important like his
parents gonna love him no matter what
they don't have to like you you have to
make them like you yeah wait this is her
boyfriend yeah her boyfriend they were
watching TV staying at the parents house
for quarantine yeah but everybody feel
like a teenager cuz you're acting like
yeah that was your first big mistake but
like honestly it's absolutely not
mistake 17 no one expected his
quarantine to last so long that's true
you know so you probably just like
wanted to be with your man and I'm sure
his parents have a nice house like in
Connecticut yeah I would like now's the
time the cabin fever sinks in so your
man's got to take the fall considering
it was his fault considering it was his
fault and honestly like if this is
someone you want to potentially marry
this is like that episode of friends
like parents always remember the kid who
smokes weed because it was Chandler and
you don't want it to be you so make a
big distinction that it was not him it
was you I mean I'm sorry it's not you it
was him okay that was your toasters are
merch is available make sure to go to
shop
morning tide shot morning toast calm we
got the four items get what choose
whether is long sleeve crop sweaters
cropped shirts shot morning toast calm
available till Sunday will keep the
store open till Sunday it's unlimited
stock so if you want something for
yourself you want to get it as a gift
for someone make sure to do it before
Sunday so it gives you plenty of time I
think that's it
that is questions about the merch or
anything else feel free to drop it in
the livestream but other than that it's
emerg isn't loading for you shop morning
toast calm the sight is working for me
on my iPad she's working for me as well
the site again try it again maybe cancel
your browser it aren't so cute
once again I'm wearing a size medium and
to show you the length of it on me I'm 5
foot 1 alright show us do a little twirl
ooh
cube you see isn't this just fabulous if
you can wear this to lunch at the
Country Club if I had one again I'm
wearing size extra large no it's yours
[Music]
Theo show us your merch wait renegade
CEO can you show us your merch perfect
for the renegade okay shot morning toast
calm y'all get your spring merch we love
ya thank you guys so much for an amazing
episode of thanks for watching the
morning toast money a morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast and we're podcasting we found
so that's quad by iTunes stitcher public
video I heard me to cashbox all the
places where ever you choose listen
podcasts find us the morning doesn't
leave a five star view about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
there are also brand new episodes of 10
and shows coming out today there's a
brand new marker Joseph's episode a
brand new mood with lauren elizabeth and
new shows coming out for the rest of the
week also another note important there
is no international shipping on this
merch drop so unfortunate but due to
like coronavirus restrictions and just
our capabilities right now it would be
so expensive and impossible so no
international orders I'm so so sorry
apology but that was the only way that
we could do at this drop love you guys
have a great day stay safe bye
you